직관을 너무 믿으면 안 되거든요. 작업 공간 qubit이 도입된 후 두 qubit의 밀도 행렬 표현을 적는 것부터 시작할 수 있어요.
그리고 qubit 순서 규칙을 평소처럼 사용한다는 점에 주목하세요.
아래 qubit이 왼쪽이고 위 qubit이 오른쪽이에요. 이 밀도 행렬을
화면에 표시된 것처럼 실제 4x4 행렬로 명시적으로 표현할 수 있고, 그런 다음 controlled-NOT gate가
이 밀도 행렬에 미치는 효과를 계산해요. 그래서 이 gate와 관련된 unitary 행렬로 켤레를 취하고,
qubit 순서 규칙을 다시 한번 염두에 두어요. 그래서 이게 올바른 unitary
행렬이고, 결과가 여기 표시돼요. 효과적으로 controlled-NOT gate가
원래 행렬의 항목들을 약간 섞었고, 이제 0이 아닐 수 있는 항목들이
네 모서리에 있어요. 부분 대각합을 계산하는 것이 남았는데, 행렬에서 직접 할 수도 있지만,
대안으로 화면에 표시된 것처럼 직접 표기법으로 변환하면 각 항에서
왼쪽의 qubit을 trace out할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지 계산하기 꽤 쉬워져요. 결과적으로
ρ의 대각 항목에 해당하는 항들만 남고, 예상대로 qubit의 위상을 제거했어요.
언제나 그렇듯이, 원하신다면 직접 여유 있게 확인해 보세요. 좋은
연습 예제로, 밀도 행렬과 부분 대각합으로 작업하는 실력을 쌓을 수 있어요.
이게 완전 위상 제거 채널을 구현하는 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 이 채널에 대한 대안적인 Stinespring 표현이 있어요.
이 영상에서 계산을 자세히 다루지는 않겠지만, 잠깐 보여드릴 거예요. 영상을 잠시 멈추고 자세히 보고 싶다면요.
작동 방식은 첫 번째와 비슷하지만 세부 사항이
달라요. 이번에는 작업 공간 qubit에 Hadamard gate로 시작해서 + 상태로 만들어요. 그리고
텐서곱을 전개하면 화면에 표시된 행렬을 얻어요. controlled-Z gate를 적용하기 위해
관련 unitary 행렬로 켤레를 취하면, 결과적으로 행렬에 일부 마이너스 부호가 삽입돼요.
특히 마지막 행과 마지막 열이 모두 -1을 곱해져요.
이번에는 직접 표기법으로 변환하면 좀 지저분하니까, 직접
부분 대각합을 계산할 거예요. 두 qubit 중 첫 번째를 trace out하면 두 대각 2x2 블록의 합이 나와요.
그래서 최종 결과는 다시 qubit의 위상이 제거된 거예요. 빠르네요. 이런 계산에 익숙하지 않다면,
천천히 여유 있게 해보세요. 속도는 중요하지 않아요.
이 예시를 마무리하기 위해, 이 구현 뒤에 꽤 간단한 아이디어가 있다는 걸 말씀드릴게요.
이건 방금 훑어본 계산의 마지막 단계에서 꽤 잘 표현돼요. 더 간결하게 말하면,
주어진 qubit 밀도 행렬과 Pauli Z 행렬로 켤레 취한 밀도 행렬을 평균하면
위상 제거와 같다는 거예요. 즉 완전 위상 제거 채널은 혼합 unitary
채널인데, 각각 1/2의 확률로 아무것도 안 하거나, 즉 항등 연산을 수행하거나, Z gate를 수행해요.
알아두면 좋아요. 요약하면, 완전 위상 제거 채널의 두 가지 다른 Stinespring 표현이 있고,
이건 중요한 것을 알려줘요. Stinespring 표현은 유일하지 않고, 실제로 주어진 채널에 대해 무한히 많이 있어요.
다음으로 Kraus 표현을 논의할 거예요. 행렬 곱셈과 덧셈을 통해 채널을 표현하는 편리한 공식적 방법을 제공해요.
Kraus 표현은 Karl Kraus의 이름을 딴 것인데, 그는 무엇보다도
채널의 기본 수학적 세부 사항을 많이 정리하고 더 넓게는 양자 정보의 일반 공식화를 연구한 물리학자예요.
일반적으로 Kraus 표현은 화면에 표시된 형태를 취하는 채널의 표현이에요. 특히
어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 A_0부터 A_이라고 불리는 행렬들의 모음이 있고, 이것들이
공식에 따라 임의의 주어진 입력 ρ에 대한 채널의 작용을 지정해요. 간단히 말해, ρ를 이 행렬들 각각으로 켤레를 취하고,
이 맥락에서 종종 Kraus 행렬이라고 불리는 이 행렬들로 켤레를 취한 다음, 결과를 합산해서 출력을 얻어요.
이 모든 행렬들은 같은 차원을 가져야 하고, 구체적으로 열이 입력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하고
행이 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응해야 해요. 그렇다면 임의의 K에 대해 A_K * ρ * A_K†의 곱을 취하면
행과 열이 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하는 정방 행렬을 얻고,
그래서 이 식이 출력 시스템의 밀도 행렬을 생성한다는 게 말이 돼요. 이제 이 Kraus 행렬들을
임의로 선택한다고 유효한 채널을 얻는 건 아니에요. 하지만 유효한 채널을 얻음을 보장하는 행렬들에 대한
꽤 간단한 조건이 있어요. 그 조건은 바로 여기 표시된 공식이에요.
구체적으로, K의 모든 값에 대해 A_K† * A_K의 곱의 합이
항등 행렬이 되어야 해요. 그리고 그 항등 행렬은 행과 열이
입력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하는 것이에요. 그 조건이 만족되어야 첫 번째 방정식으로 정의된 사상이
유효한 채널이 돼요. 그리고 모든 채널은 n을 충분히 크게 취하는 한
실제로 이 형태를 취하는 표현을 갖는 것으로 밝혀졌어요. 여기 Kraus 표현의 몇 가지 예시가 있어요.
qubit 리셋 채널부터 시작해서, |0⟩⟨0|와 |0⟩⟨1|이라는 두 개의 Kraus 행렬을 사용해서
이 채널의 Kraus 표현을 얻을 수 있어요. 이 예시에서 n은 2와 같아요.
이 선택들을 일반 공식에 대입하면 두 항만 있어서, 합을 쉽게 적을 수 있어요.
단순화하고 괄호 안의 식이 ρ의 대각합임을 인식하면, qubit 리셋 채널을 얻는다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
또한 이 행렬들에 대한 필요한 조건이 충족되는지 확인할 수 있는데, Kraus 행렬들을
방정식에 대입하고 계산하는 단순한 문제이고, 필요한 대로 항등 행렬을 얻어요. 또 다른 예시로 완전 위상 제거 채널을
다시 살펴봐요. |0⟩⟨0|와 |1⟩⟨1| 행렬을 취하면 작동하고, 합을 전개해서
필요한 것을 꽤 직접적으로 얻는지 확인할 수 있어요. 다시 한번 필요한 조건이 충족돼요.
대안은 A_0를 I/√2로, A_1을
σ_Z/√2로 취하는 거예요. 계산하면 다시 완전 위상 제거 채널을 얻는다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
앞서 관찰한 것에 기반해서요.